against we'll try a
adhi for a game what's up active guard
all right um this is different
Bishop g5
croisine 17 thank you for the two months
in a row man
all right um let's just
put-upon on e3
mm-hmm I know I really don't want a week
in any of my ponds so
I know left three
and let's go see for
c4 Knight c3
I'm fine with that
okay Wow
this is transitioning into a Dutch
structure where I have my bad bishop
outside my pawn chain okay I'm not even
going to do this move just going to
develop develop develop
I guess this is pretty logical they have
a ton of support for it that is the idea
g6 is that about
all right tell you what I'm gonna go
here
and I just want to jump in well this is
a
very similar to a game I already played
where once again it's about all over the
key differences on the e-file
this is a hole this isn't
all right let's ask him a question
though I'm gonna take or go elsewhere
here's a runs into Knight takes c6
let's step up
mm-hmm I'm going for the same maneuver
preparing f3
okay we once again I mean all these
little details may end up going down
that same exact road one where I end up
with a good Bishop versus bad bishop or
a good knight versus bad bishop
something playing against this bad
Bishop one way or the other
taking I don't want the structure to
change at this point alright let's play
night here my idea
this they're not doing anything about
that
if they were a little bit faster with
this move instead of this move then it
would be a different story
if I go here he'll be challenged
straightaway
let's put a rook in the center I'm
eyeing up this idea Queen exchange
what's getting a flight square something
useful he remains behind enemy lines
that's actually a pretty interesting
move
don't want to see a capture and then
some push they're playing playing
extremely fast extremely fast
so I'm offered this file and I'm
combating this advance let's put a rook
here
yeah I really need to pick up the pace I
think
all right I'm going to change the
structure
therefore I don't have to do
so now some of my worry of a capture
here and then a push I don't know I
don't have that worry anymore and here's
the other thing I want to play without
f4 I'm going to just go here and I want
to work with this square now so my queen
could take up a very nice residence on
d4 and I think she should do that right
now
let's do it right now so play is going
to follow in the kingside next
I with that move I feel like I could
already run my King over here and then
play in the Kings side
all right let's um
[Music]
let's go here I know I'm opposite this
but
are they going to do anything to combat
my idea
and Scott G for right now
prepare to double
you
they continue to place so fast
you
Queens off okay
you
I have all day
in this position and I'm going to take
all day
this is not this is like a Solomon's key
position
they're just shuffling but I'm going to
make progress here I am definitely going
to make progress
that's the nice thing about the
increment
let's just go here maybe this I don't
know let's back up he's more versatile
on g1 could look at this
I'm gonna continue with this little
journey put my king right on this square
keep going
keep going surrounding the rook all
right so now we crack things open over
here and now there's a great restriction
with the black pieces
let's do it break it open
the bishop may be trapped in the end of
the vicious if the rooks are exchanged
King here and the bishops dead
all right we're smashing through here
and exactly what I was pointing out is
going to happen Bishop is now dead
let's just put an end to this guy going
any further
and my king is just going to mop up
everything the king is now boxed out
and just resigned
I don't know that felt like they were
just playing too fast and
they were doing a lot of shuffling
no they had to at least take a time out
to think and come up with some plan
because that's a position type where I
could continually improve little by
little but just like I did with the king
you